>> Hi, I would like to introduce
our open source platform
called OpenPAI.
This is the landing page
of the platform.
You can see that, right now,
OpenPAI managed
more than 200 GPUs
on Azure GPU VMs.
From this page, you can see a set
of jobs running on top of PAI,
and we can include
a certain keyword to find
those jobs of interest.
For example, in this case,
I would like to find all the
jobs in the running stage.
You can see that
right now there are
more than 70 jobs
in running stage.
I can also click
one of the job to see the
overall information of the job.
For example, this job
use four GPUs
and they use one container,
four GPUs, with
two parts available.
Also, we can see
the job configuration
of these job and we
can copy those job
configuration into
a local file and use
this configuration to
submit a job again.
So, you can easily reproduce
this job on a cluster.
We can also provide
some information for you to
remotely log into this running
job to do remote debug.
Also, we use this hardware page
to monitor the overall GPU,
CPU, essential hardware resource
usage for this particular job.
OpenPAI support the concept
called a virtual cluster where
multiple teams can share
a physical cluster with
different virtual clusters.
For example, in this cluster,
we have three virtual clusters
with different hardware
capacity configured.
We also provide
some monitoring tools
to show the healthiness of
different PAI components.
For example, in this case,
all the components shown in green
means the PAI service
are in healthy state.
We also provide
a user management.
You can add new users and
assign the user different
access permission
to different virtual clusters.
If you are interested in PAI,
please visit our GitHub website
and we have a detailed document
to introduce how to
deploy and operate and
how to use OpenPAI.
Thank you.